>> Mathematical morphology sounds complicated but it's really just
about using mathematical operations to change or morph images.
The first operation we are going to look at is called dilation.
To see how this works, let's imagine we have
a black and white image in which
a pixel value of 255 indicates white,
and zero indicates black.
We start by creating a mask which we call a structuring element.
This contains pixel values and has
a target cell called this origin,
usually somewhere near the center.
In this case, our structuring element is
a basic cross pattern of black cells.
But you can use any shape you like really
depending on the effect you want to have on the image.
Now, we place the structuring element
on the image just like a filter,
and we look for pixels where
the underlying image value
matches the overlaid structuring element value.
If we find any, we activate the target cell by setting it to zero.
In other words, we're performing a logical OR-operation on
any cell in the structuring element
that matches a cell in the image.
In this case, there are none,
so we move on to the next cell.
Now, the middle cell on the bottom row of
the mass contains a zero,
and so does the corresponding image cell.
So our criteria of finding any cells with a matching value is met,
and we set the target cell to zero.
Let me just repeat the operation,
convolving the mask across
the image until all the target cells are set.
You can see from this that
the key effect of dilation is to enlarge
images by extending pixels around
the edges and to fill-in small holes.
Erosion, as its name suggests,
is the opposite of dilation.
It removes pixels in details from the image.
We'll start with the end result from our dilation process,
and once again, we'll apply a structuring element.
But this time when we compare the cells,
we'll use a logical AND.
In other words, we'll set the target cell to
zero only in cases where all of the cells match.
Otherwise, we'll set it to 255 and make it white.
For example, at this point,
not all of the cells match.
So we'll set the target cell to 255.
Then we'll just repeat that across the entire image,
and our erosion process that
removed a layer of cells at the edges.
We've also lost the rounded edges.
One of the effect of erosion is to remove fine detail.
Now, let's consider what's happened to our image so far.
We started with this image of
a black solid cross inside a black square.
Then we apply dilation,
which had the effect of extending
the edge pixels and filling-in the gaps.
Finally, we applied erosion,
which remove the edge pixels again,
so we ended up with the original square with the gaps filled-in.
The net effect of applying dilation
followed by erosion is called closing.
Now, the opposite of closing is opening,
and we could do that by performing
the same operations in the opposite order.
So we could start with the same image
and then this time apply erosion,
which removes the pixels around
the edge and loses some of the detail.
Then we apply dilation,
which adds pixels to the edges.